>> Laura: HEARING DEMOCRATS
CLAIMING TO BE THE MORE TOLERANT
PARTY.
WHY ARE THE 2020 HOPEFULS
HURLING VIOLENT RHETORIC?
MATT SCHLAPP, RICHARD GOODSTEIN.
I WANT TO TAKE YOU TO THE
LANGUAGE.
EARLIER TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALKED ABOUT HOW HE WAS
TARGETING NEW STATES AHEAD OF
2020.
SO WHAT ARE HIS POTENTIAL
OPPONENTS TARGETING?
HERE'S CORY BOOKER.
>> MY TESTOSTERONE SOMETIMES
MAKES ME WANT TO FEEL LIKE
PUNCHING HIM.
>> Laura: OKAY, WE REALLY NEED
TO PLAY A LONGER VERSION OF THAT
ABOUT WHAT WAS THAT LAST NIGHT?
THAT WAS IN WASN'T A MOMENT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO MAKE PUBLIC ATTACKS
OR REFERENCES TO ATTACKING THE
PRESIDENT.
SECOND OF ALL, THEIR WHOLE THING
IS ABOUT HOW TRUMP'S LANGUAGE IS
OUT-OF-BOUNDS AND CAUSING THIS
HOSTILITY.
THIS MAN IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AND THAT'S THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES HAVE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE PRACTICAL.
DO THEY THINK THESE PEOPLE ARE
READY TO LEAD WITH STATEMENTS
LIKE THAT?
>> Laura: RICHARD, AGAIN, THE
LONGER VERSION IS ACTUALLY
REALLY HILARIOUS.
THAT WAS A STRANGE MOMENT.
YOUR REACTION.
I KIND OF KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO SAVE A GO-AHEAD.
>> REMINISCENT OF WHAT TRUMP AND
BIDEN TALKED ABOUT.
WHEN DEMOCRATS HEAR THAT CROWD
CHANTING "SEND HER BACK," AND
TRUMP SITS BACK FOR 13 SECONDS
AND DOES NOTHING AND THEN SAYS I
TRIED TO STOP IT.
LIKE WE ARE ALL IDIOTS AND BLIND
AND THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS
VIDEOTAPED.
IT DOES MAKE PEOPLE FEEL PRETTY
ANGRY.
HIS PUNCHING HIM IN THE FACE THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE?
NO.
BUT I DO THINK HE GIVES RISE TO
THAT, WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT I
THINK FRANKLY THE REPUBLICANS
LOST THE 2018 ELECTIONS.
>> D- I JUST SAY THE THING ABOUT
HOW DEMOCRATS GET TRIGGERED OR
UPSET ABOUT WHAT THESE AMERICAN
AMERICANS, 7,000 AMERICANS FEEL.
CAN YOU UNDERSTAND HOW UPSET
THEY ARE WHEN THEY HEAR THE
SQUAD AND THE OTHER SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS RUNNING DOWN AMERICA,
RUNNING DOWN AMERICAN VALUES.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE UPSET.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE RACIST
OR THEY HAVE RACIAL BIGOTRY.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
PEOPLE HERE THAT DON'T
APPRECIATE THE BEAUTY OF A
MIRACLE.
>> THEY HAVE RUN THIS COUNTRY
DOWN NO MORE THAN THE PRESIDENT
FROM THE CAPITOL BUILDING
TALKING ABOUT AMERICAN CARNAGE
AND HOW THERE IS NO SUCH THING
AS AMERICAN EXCEPTIONALISM.
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN THAT COLORFUL
AND RUNNING DOWN THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: HE DIDN'T SAY THERE
WAS NO SUCH THING AS AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM.
I THINK HE WAS TRYING TO SAY THE
THINGS OF GOTTEN OUT OF CONTROL
WORK WHEN YOU TRY TO GET THEM
BACK UNDER CONTROL.
IT'S A LOFTY GOAL.
THE ECONOMY IS DOING PRETTY WELL
WE HAVE A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO TRY TO
GET UP I WANT TO GET TO A SECOND
EXAMPLE.
HERE'S PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY
DEFENDING THE BETSY ROSS FLAG
AFTER THE BACKLASH AGAINST NIKE
EARLIER THIS MONTH.
>> HOW ABOUT THE BETSY ROSS --
ISN'T IT TERRIBLE CUSTOMER THEY
TRY TO TAKE YOUR HERITAGE AWAY.
THEN YOU SEE THE PICTURE OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA WITH THE SAME
EXACT FLAG.
IT'S VERY UNFAIR WHAT THEY DO.
THEY TRY TO DEMEAN AND BEING
LITTLE AND THEY ARE VERY GOOD AT
IT.
THEY ARE BETTER THAT THAN THEY
ARE POLITICS.
THEY ARE BETTER AT THAT THAN THE
ART POLICY.
>> WHEN HE RUNS AGAINST
COLIN KAEPERNICK FOR PRESIDENT,
HE'LL HAVE A GREAT ISSUE.
I DON'T HEAR ANY DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE TALKING
ABOUT THE BETSY ROSS FLAG.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT -- TRULY
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HEALTH CARE.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE, ALL THE THINGS.
>> Laura: WHY ARE THEY NOT
DENOUNCING THE ANTI-AMERICANISM?
>> WHY IS IT NOT EVERY
REPUBLICAN DENOUNCING THE
PRESIDENT'S TWEETS QUESTION
MARKS.
DO THEY KNOW HE'S NOT A RACIST.
>> WHAT HE'S SAYING IT'S RACIST,
GIVEN HIS HISTORY.
>> Laura: WHITNEY, LET ME, LET
ME.
WERE NOT DOING LATELY.
COMPARED TO THE KENNEDY
BETO O'ROURKE.
>> WE SAW NORTH CAROLINA WAS
ALMOST AN IMPROMPTU NUREMBERG
RALLY.
>> Laura: STANDING UP FOR THE
FLAG VERSUS IMPUGNING AMERICANS?
>> DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
PROBLEMS IS NOT WITH TRUMP.
IT'S WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S WHAT THESE PEOPLE THINK
THAT THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
AND IT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM.
THEY ATTACKED THOSE PEOPLE IN
NORTH CAROLINA, THEY ARE
ATTACKING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND IT'S NOT
A WINNING STRATEGY.
>> Laura: I THINK TRUMP TAPS
INTO THE SENSITIVE AMERICANS ARE
AFRAID THAT THEY CAN'T SPEAK
WITHOUT BEING BRANDED A RACIST
AND THEY CAN'T THINK AMERICA IS